[Music]
in destroyed history news submitted by
wiggle my toes I could do it all from
Kill Bill almost a billion dollars has
been pledged to rebuild the not to Dame
Cathedral after the fire know what
caused yeah so so basically so the
cathedral hadn't really been well to
give me rights in perspective the the
cathedral is eight hundred and fifty
years old
but it was built in like I don't even
know how to say two-year it was like one
one zero zero yeah eleven sixty
something like that but the yeah eleven
eleven sixty one one zero zero you know
that's how I would say it if I saw that
year that that's how far back like eight
hundred fifty years old doesn't mean as
much to me as built in one one six zero
that's crazy so basically they weren't
really taking like the cathedral is a
beautiful tourist spot but it was very
expensive and they weren't really
keeping up with too much upkeep so they
have finally signed on to do this six
point eight million dollar renovation
and somebody was saying that like you
know some of the bricks are unstable
some of the like equipment that they
were bringing in it just wasn't really a
good idea so the company that was
working on it that's how the fire
started
they haven't release all the details
online you know exactly but it was
undergoing renovations and during the
renovation that's from the fire this is
what happened detective Joe I'll explain
what happened right like detective job
there's like some French construction
guys right there working Pierre it
appears smoking you know they love
smoking like yeah [ __ ] guy can't
believe up they threw the cigarette like
that then they threw it on the ground
and it started to burn I like that you
said sacrebleu that's the only French
thing I know yeah oh I'm they do fromage
I don't know if that's correct in this
Bonjour I don't know
don't know any French we know let me
know watching it I only know what I know
you're not popular mom pop gasa no it's
like well I think it's I only speak
French a little bit poquito laughs
laughs it'll be funny if someone that
doesn't speak English at all comes out
to you right and just something super
random saying oh there's water
unfiltered yeah but they don't speak
English at all yeah that's the only
thing they like dance do you let your
hair up or does it like just know it is
in the way a little bit no I was
thinking with mine I guess in the way
it's going to armpit I think so you know
actually when I turn yeah it has my face
and it's like a whip in it yeah your
hair is like hey my ring yes recently I
did a random shoot where don't ask me
why but I was like Oh wonder what I look
like if that if it looks like the braids
going through the face right so we did
that so obviously you have to cut it and
then I was like oh what do I should do
after the shoot like I don't want it to
just be you know but then this was still
there so was like oh I've never seen it
before
that is cool all right look at this
[ __ ] fire y'all this schism
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah okay so that's so sexual
picture if I meet you up in there like
three times
really yeah it's [ __ ] beautiful
inside and it's all this [ __ ] so like
did you guys ever go up the tower no
we've never like to me like yeah my back
deep not a new building burns are all
they give a [ __ ] but like when things
are irreplaceable
any country any culture it's just like
oh man that's the time in the history
yeah there's so much history especially
from 1161 one six zero this is oh dude
it really is this is one of my personal
favorite photos I don't know if you guys
saw this on Twitter but there was a user
that took this image because you can see
the cross is still intact and like there
was another image where like the Sun was
really coming down on that cross and
this person was like like after all that
burns the cross still remains I don't
know why you can't believe in God after
this and then someone responded and was
like well because a wood fire burns at
600 degrees Celsius and at 1,000 degrees
Celsius its spiritualist [ __ ] there
though so we've seen this we've seen
mass happen and like so first of all
what are the the Pope's minions called
children no they still got the [ __ ]
drapes and [ __ ] that a bishop is that a
friar maybe bishop so maybe like bishops
and car you can I don't know but these
[ __ ] so they thought this the
building's gotta be like a hundred
like on the inside these fools bring it
oh [ __ ]
so these fools they bring in them I
don't know where they find found this
double-xl Bible the Bible was like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know why
oh so he carries it in like this he puts
it here and when he [ __ ] turns the
page squat to it right he's like and
then this full night's incense and start
swinging at you like what the [ __ ] when
you and there's like a little hole I
think when the Sun comes in I think
that's probably design it back then to
make you feel like all right and when
you see the smoke going in and the
acoustics you're just like oh my god
Christian he became Christian Christian
right now cuz these young music is like
kind of sick but welcome Christian man I
wonder if the Bible burned big eyes what
do you think they were like holy [ __ ]
get the
Bible in French the be bleh I made it up
that will be so sad save a lot of stuff
that's good yeah actually so and here's
the final picture from the fire so this
is kind of the aftermath after its
distinguished like so the front part
with the two towers is still pretty much
believe I'm so like from the front it
looks pretty normal
how's the Hunchback though is he okay
dude I when I like I did not everyone
will say oh another Notre Dame because
it was on fire and I'm like like that's
that's the first thing that I thought
too because I've never I've never been
to Paris you you out there listening to
hymns and [ __ ] like it they won't let me
leave
I can't there's [ __ ] relics in there
did you know one of Jesus's borns from
his Thorncrown is inside there damn it
no yeah we saw it like legit nobody's
saying this
one like the historical do not like the
religious like but they don't have a
picture of him because I want the iPhone
back could somebody could have doodled
something y'all could keep his crime
chalking it doodle a picture no way too
fast that God was drawing and the god he
left he's already gone I was on water
like how is he's going when it could be
on watch there's relics in there hello
relic charlie relics and goblets and
[ __ ] and drapes holy relic just want to
know cuz cuz I grew up looking at black
Jesus and then when we left the church I
was I hope interested well you had black
Jesus yeah like they look like a dude
with dreads are you Rastafarian no no no
no no yeah I was born in a a Christian I
was I was going to happen there what
well I went to a church and it was like
backwoods country Virginia Church um it
like yes I saw the fade no but I think
about it he had been drawn by a white
person because the texture of the hair
did not match that of an afro-american
man oh that's right sure it's just that
they just like put they just darkened it
a little bit yeah so yeah when I saw
white Jesus I was like yeah it was those
weird I just I want to know my Jesus
looked like a game of Thrones character
and maybe a Lannister Party guy would
mean your Jesus the one that I was in my
oh yeah yeah yeah we probably had the
same Jesus yeah mine had blue eyes
alright so the so the President of
France who by the way I didn't know was
lowkey kind of fine I mean fine for like
a president
you feel me I know Jimmy like
presidential fine he's like kind of like
low-key fine for like a president like
people thought John F Kennedy was fine
as hell yeah younger if he wasn't a
president he looks like he looks like
Mad TV guy that Canadian the Canadian
doll
yeah that one like even like Monica
Lewinsky like she's busted as [ __ ] on
the streets but when you're when you're
like surrounded by like con
congressional like twos and throw your
right she's a super mom that's true
so this is this is what he loves my girl
Shh there we go oh yeah seven yeah like
we're like a president he's like you
know I didn't life is like way older
than him though it's kind of a trip oh
he got him a sugar mama yeah mm-hmm and
she was like oh you can't be President
one day so he does like you know come to
Jesus talk of everyone he's like hey we
need donations I'm trying to get the
church built in the next five years
there's like it's gonna take like up to
20 of those yeah they said that it took
a hundred years to build the church he
wants it done in five years I'm like
you're fine but you're not logical you
know it took a hundred years to build
more than technology
you could public John yeah I mean I get
it but I don't know anybody that could
stick to the job for a hundred years
yeah that's contracts at like 40 years I
think people be like [ __ ] it bro well
look at that no dude look at the church
in Barcelona still building yeah for I
don't know how many hundreds of years
yeah really it's but you know why it
takes so long in Spain they take a lot
of breaks yeah check it out from India
it took a lot of siesta so it's taken
that long going when I was a kid and it
was like oh it's gonna be built like
it's gonna take hundreds of years or
whatever so I think it's almost done and
I need a contract China no but don't
finish don't finish in like three weeks
yeah and then they'll probably be like
horrible like know what they're doing
out there they're building whole entire
cities like their coffee whole entire
European cities and then they're
propping that [ __ ] up in China the
popularity has but note Saddam in China
right now so I'm gonna tell y'all my
favorite personal piece of information
that I found out I don't know how this
happened I don't know what the policies
on these things are but the church was
not insured
there was no light it's owned by the
government yeah but they I guess I mean
like I feel like historical pieces is
Stonehenge insured is like a different
thing no not good they're like we don't
need insurance we got Jesus yeah there's
there's absolutely no insurance on the
building also probably because nobody
would insure that [ __ ] because they'd
be like you know how much is it worth
it's worth this priceless yeah so there
was no insurance on it so they're
sticking to public donations but they
have raised over a billion dollars I
think money is still coming in
millionaire that came in and donated I
think 208 million didn't like Salma
Hayek's husband donate some [ __ ] yeah
yeah I don't know about Salma Hayek but
her husband billionaire I think you did
like I understand its historical
significance but why are people so
passionate about nor ordered I'm I don't
know their lives like all these French
people it's like it's kind of like ours
that's rural Liberty I guess for the non
French people right
like outside photos in front of that
thing I think for me for me it's from
like an empathy point of view where like
I've only visited it like a couple times
I never lived in I never lived in France
but I know how much that means to them
so it'd be like if like if the Forbidden
City I'm not even like from China but
like the Forbidden City in and out
started burning down national treasure
if all the way ain't announced burned
down at once no it would be a tragedy
don't we need a billion dollars the
Hollywood sign no I think that's what it
is being in LA in California we don't
have anything that's 800 years centuries
to use deepened I mean whoa we have the
San Gabriel mission right here that's
probably a couple hundred how many times
have we been there once
[Music]